What happens when a copy of a video game and
a USB drive of manga are placed in SCP-914?
Dr. Tiori selected a copy of "The Elder Scrolls
V: Skyrim" and a USB drive containing the
entirety of the manga "Jojo’s Bizarre Adventure
Part 5: Vento Aureo" for testing.
First, the video game was placed inside on
the setting "1:1."
The output produced was a copy of "The Elder
Scrolls IV: Oblivion."
Next, the USB drive was placed inside on the
setting "Fine."
The output was one USB drive containing an
animated adaptation of “Jojo’s Bizarre
Adventure Part 5: Vento Aureo” with English
subtitles - years before the real adaptation
came out.
Dr. Tiori elected to keep the new USB drive
for herself, for research purposes only, of
course!